it is a genuine privilege
does have lecture I have long been a
supporter of ancient history as Joe
mentioned but I've also been a consumer
of ancient history both as an historian
and as a political scientist I hope that
my remarks tonight don'tjust I don'tjust
justify my consumption of ancient
history but provide some questions or
themes that ancient historians might
find useful in thinking about the
development of states in the ancient
world I should also mention that the
work some of the work tonight some of
the ideas tonight are jointly authored
with one of my former PhD students
victim in eldo now an assistant
professor at the University of
Washington so anything sensible I say we
should attribute to Victor and anything
unreasonable attribute to me I'd like to
start with a puzzle and it's a puzzle
that comes out of the political science
literature and that puzzle is that the
world is tends to be divided into
countries that have been stable
democracies or persistent autocracies
there are countries in red on the map
our countries that have never at any
time in their history scored above 7 a-7
or above on the political science metric
called the polity score so France for
example would be a 7 so the countries
that are in red have never in their
history score 27 some of them such as
Egypt in Iraq have never have never been
democracies ever at any time with in
recorded history that is Egypt since 30
150 bc in iraq since 2300 BC when Sargon
of Akkad United the city-state's of
Mesopotamia that suggests my mind anyway
a high degree of persistence the
countries in green are our countries
that have been democracy since at least
1991 you might ask why start 1991 and
the answer is because that's when the
former Soviet Union broke up if you
don't do 1991 you have to drop a bunch
of
countries if you push it back in time
what will happen is that the countries
of Latin America will turn white because
they oscillated back and forth between
democracy and autocracy and Eastern
Europe also will will not get coated at
all but it won't affect this map in any
dramatic way and so one of the big
questions and political science is well
why is the world developed why is the
world organized this way why do we have
countries that are persistently
democratic countries that are
persistently autocratic and in some
countries that sort of bounce back and
forth so political scientists have put
forward a number of theories to explain
this I won't spend a lot of time on them
one which came out of the 1950s was that
those countries became richer they could
they would become Democratic it turns
out in recent work by Darren sa moglo
and co-authors that that's a spurious
result then there was a theory
associated with Guillermo donnell in the
1970s called bureaucratic
authoritarianism I won't go through the
details of the theory but when people
actually looked at evidence they found
there was only one case of it okay I
thought that was funny then there's the
famous work of Angermann install cool
off and I say mogu Johnson and Robinson
in which they suggested that well
there's something about climate and
disease environments and soils that
determines the kind of society again and
and the kind of society you get is what
determines whether you'll be democratic
or autocratic and whether you'll grow or
be poor they're definitely on to
something I'm going to suggest in this
talk but the way they set up their tests
excluded Europe the Middle East Central
Asia South Asia in East Asia meaning
there's a lot of the world left to be
explained the final the big Theory grand
theory is the resource curse and this is
the one that is generally an except in
political science except it is what's
called a robust fact a fact that we all
accept as true the basic idea is that
countries that have lots of point source
natural resources oil gas and minerals
are less like
to be democracies that is reliance on
those minerals is going to prevent
democratic transitions or undermine
existing democracies there's a huge case
study literature that begins in Middle
East Studies and move to African Studies
which supports the theory in fact which
gave rise to the theory and then there's
a large cross country regression
literature beginning with work by Robert
Barrow all the through all the way
through a recent paper by Dan trees Minh
that finds that there is a robust
association between autocracy and
producing or exporting a lot of natural
resources where natural resources here
are defined as these point source
resources if you look at a map of the
world it seems somewhat intuitive here's
all the countries that are autocracies
and have always been so here is the
countries which have large amounts of
oil and you'll see that in fact the
countries many but not all of the
countries with large amounts of oil
particularly Saudi Arabia Iraq Iran the
United Arab Emirates here in the Middle
East are persistent autocracies and so
the basis of this literature that is the
basis of the empirical claim that this
exists is finding a correlation between
lots of oil or lots of oil minerals and
autocracy I'm going to explain in this
lecture why that is spurious we actually
don't know which way causality is
running whether it's running from
autocracy to having a lot of oil but
more deeply what this and what the
theory implies is that had these
countries not found oil gas and minerals
they would have become democratic and
I'm going to suggest that history show
history indicates that that's highly
unlikely but i'll come back to this the
theory that connects the mechanism that
connects oil gas and minerals to
persistent autocracy is very appealing
that is just as there was no taxation
without representation in the US
revolution there can be
no no representation without taxation so
if you are producing lots of oil gas and
minerals and the government can tax it
directly there's no need to trade
representative institutions to the
citizenry in exchange for taxes instead
you're going to rent to your state which
has the ability to repress citizens and
buy off the opposition so this is the
theory that cute ative Lee explains or
the puter Lee is the mechanism that
connects oil gas and minerals to
autocracy this literature has very had
very wide purchase it's reported as a
robust fact in the scholarly political
economy literature especially
Huntington's 1991 book third wave in
policy papers written at the World Bank
in popular books on world politics and
economics including Thomas Friedman's
the world is flat and Paul Colliers the
bottom billion and even in the mass
media Rosenberg 2007 is in New York
sunday New York Times Magazine article
and of course Friedman's famous are a
column the first law of petrol politics
which appeared in New York Times and
which later on became a foreign affairs
article okay so what's my purpose here
first to demonstrate that the theory of
the resource curse does not square with
the history of modern states and this is
work that's coming out a co-author
between Victor and I and the APS are
second to demonstrate that the history
or the theory of the resource curse also
does not square with what we know about
ancient states third to propose a
different theory geography does in fact
matter it just doesn't matter in the way
the resource curse people think it
matters rather i'm going to advance a
theory that patterns of rainfall
explained variance and regime types and
forth to show that that theory is
consistent with evidence both from the
modern world and the ancient world okay
the point of departure of this lecture
is that history did not begin in
nineteen fifty for those of you in
classics departments i'm sure this is
not a surprise i should mention oh
nineteen fifty bc its nineteen fifty ad
the way the political science will the
comparative politics literature in
political science got set up was it was
a cold war enterprise and what was to be
explained was why democracy hadn't
triumph everywhere in the 20th century
and so it was focused on the period
since nineteen fifty that was one reason
why this the literature had a president
present this focus but it also relied
for these cross-country regressions that
people ran on data sets that were put
together by international organizations
which didn't come into existence until
the 1950s so implicitly history starts
in almost all these studies in 1950 now
I don't think it would take especially
in this audience much time to
demonstrate to you that a history didn't
start 1950 but more importantly that
autocracy and democracy were not
invented in 1950 in fact it's those are
major themes that is what kind of regime
type do you have and what effect does it
have in the economy were major themes in
rostov saves work published back in the
1920s particularly his social and
economic history of Rome and his history
of the ancient world not surprisingly
jean types were a major concern of the
thinkers of antiquity the acidities
Plato and Aristotle in particular so the
the point I want to make here is that we
need to take time seriously in fact the
countries that we think of today as the
most durable authoritarian states the
places that launched the resource curse
literature such as Iraq and Iran were
autocracies in antiquity unless you take
a strongly postmodern view of time's
arrow something that happened in the
20th century could not have caused
something that happened in 2350 BC Iraq
has been an autocracy since Sargon of
Akkad Egypt has been an autocracy since
the first Pharaoh Iran has been an
autocracy
persistence the RK amended empire the
countries that experiment with democracy
antiquity particularly the greek city
city states in the Roman Republic kept
experimenting with all talk with
democracy the Italy in the 11th to the
15th century when we had the Italian
city-states communes and grease on five
different occasions from its
independence from the Ottoman Empire in
1832 the present and of course Italy
persistently since the 1940s with the
defeat fascism what's interesting on the
point I want to make is these places
have never experimented with democracy
these places repeatedly have it suggests
that there's some equilibrium conditions
that drive one set of countries towards
autocracy in another towards democracy
and that that could not be caused by a
20th century event historians in the
audience may ask why bother with the
theory at all I should mention that I
started my career as an historian and
still have a foot very much in history
and the short answer is without theory
there's no framework with which to order
facts and a causal narrative even the
most traditional historian one who
simply puts one fact after another in
chronological framework is in fact
imposing a theory on the data I want to
be very clear here that a theory is not
a replacement for knowing what actually
happened it's an input to understanding
what actually happened it is a framework
with which to order the facts this is
true for history but it is also true for
all other fields in fact it's the
history that gives us the story when we
for those of us who do econometrics it's
the history that provides the story that
that is that underlies the the
parameters in any regression model what
political signs
they're trying to do in stories about
why the world is democratic or parts of
the world or democratic and parts of the
world or autocratic is they're trying to
craft an historical narrative about the
distribution of democracies and
autocracies and in this sense I want to
underline there is a lot of common
ground between history and political
science as well as economics a common
ground that I think is not exploited
sufficiently how can we know if a theory
because I'm going to present one tonight
and many of you may be skeptical I said
ice I suspect that my discussant
professor lamoreaux is skeptical I
welcomed her skepticism and I'm happy
for it because I may well be wrong how
do we know if I'm wrong well we can
think of two kinds of theories a
deterministic theory which can be
falsified by a single case that does not
fit the theory for example easy
deterministic Theory theory of gravity
we know that if I step off the edge of
this stage that I'm going to fall and
likely hurt myself but we definitely
know I'm going to fall nobody believes
that there's any probability i will zoom
to the other side of room like neo in
the matrix my daughter was young she
believed it but she doesn't believe in
anymore she's a teenager now um so a
single case could falsify a theory of
that nature what I'm going to make
tonight is a probabilistic theory
example of a probabilistic theory is
smoking causes cancer everybody in this
room I think believes that smoking
causes cancer but we all know somebody
who had a great-uncle who met somebody
ones who smoked like a chimney and lived
to be 110 the fact that that man lived
to be a hundred and ten does not falsify
the theory that smoking causes cancer
that's the kind of argument i'm going to
make tonight it is more likely the case
that certain kinds of rainfall
conditions give are more likely to
produce democracy
and it is likely the case that the
absence of rainfall gives rise to
autocracies but it is not determinative
there's two ways we can know if I'm
wrong the first is we can't find the
systemic systemic tendency that matches
the empirical prediction of the theory
and the second is if we can't find
evidence for the mechanism that's
hypothesized to link the cause and the
effect I'll come back to this later okay
so let me start before talking about
patterns of rainfall let me explain why
the excellent raining Theory has got to
be wrong that's the theory of the
resource curse the resource curse is a
dynamic theory it says that something
happened in the past that is the
discovery of oil gas or minerals that
sent a country down a different path of
institutional development than it would
have followed otherwise that the
discovery of oil gas and minerals cursed
the country what do they have in mind
well imagine here a country in red which
is chugging along at a high level of
democracy oils discovered or oral
minerals discovered at point x 7 and the
country goes down a different path of
political development than it would have
otherwise had it not found them it would
have remained highly democratic or
here's a country which would have
democratized had it not found oil moving
up in blue but because it found
resources democracy was blocked and so
it continued to have a what's called a
low poly score this is the standard
metric and political science or the
country did democratize here in blue
democracy increasing a polity score
going up but because it found excuse me
it should have democratized as fast as
his purple line but because they found
oil gas and minerals it democratized
more slowly than it would have otherwise
and so the point I simply want to make
is the way the literature has been
constructed they don't actually
look to see whether any of these things
really happen instead what they do is
they pull the world and they run
regressions that is they're looking for
systematic patterns and the data but
they're essentially comparing because
they're not taking time into account
they're essentially comparing England to
Saudi Arabia controlling for different
characteristics like the percentage of
the population that's Muslim and per
capita GDP I will run I'm not going to
spend too much time talking about the
regression frameworks the bottom line is
this I can get PowerPoint to work
they're saying that had Saudi Arabia not
discovered oil it would have had the
same political institutions as Denmark
controlling for the fact that Denmark
has fewer Muslims and a lower per capita
GDP I don't think it would take a long
time to convince you that that's a very
strong assumption so Rick turn right now
no no I wanted to really test this and
here's what we did we look for evidence
that countries actually went down a
different path of development we wanted
to know did as they discovered oil gas
and minerals did they become less
democratic more democratic or did it
have no effect at all in order to do
that we had to take history seriously so
we went out we built data sets on the
percentage of government income that
came from oil gas and minerals for 18 of
the major natural resource producers in
the world since independence on total
oil income for every country in the
world since 1800 on total fuel income
which concludes natural gas and call for
every country in the world since 1900 on
total fueled medals income for every
country in the world since 1900 and a
total oil reserves since nineteen forty
three and what we then did was torture
the data we spent three years it's a
good thing that the opportunity cost of
my time is very low because it took us
three years to gather the data and then
learn old statistical techniques
necessary to do the tests so for those
members of the audience
who know about such things first we
estimated single country error
correction model regressions for every
country in the data set to see if we
could find evidence for a single country
in its time series of a connection
between increases in oil lower democracy
we couldn't find anything we then
created panels and we estimated panel
ECM regressions and we couldn't find
anything we then played with the lag
structure of these regressions and we
couldn't find anything we then you split
sample techniques looking at countries
that were very poor when they found oil
or minerals versus countries that were
very rich or that had did unequal
distribution of income or that had bed
institutions or good institutions or
that were in a particular geographic
region of the world or that found the
oil a particular time and no matter what
we did we couldn't find the predicted
negative coefficients on oil influencing
the polity score so then we added a
battery of control variables things like
per capita GDP percent population Muslim
than the percentage of the countries in
the world that were Democratic the
percentage of the countries in your
region that were Democratic etc and we
still couldn't find the predicted
results we then thought well maybe
causalities running backwards so we did
instrumental variable regressions and we
couldn't find the predicted results and
finally we said well maybe it's we have
to think counterfactual e so we use
what's called a difference indifference
estimator where we created a synthetic
country that didn't find oil sort of a
Venezuela that never found oil and
compared it to Venezuela's actual polity
score and then saw whether the
difference was a function of the amount
of oil Venezuela produced and when we
did that in fact when we need all these
torturing zuv the data we kept coming up
with regression parameters or regression
coefficients that have the wrong sign
positive and statistically significant
and so what it said is that more oil
minerals more democracy no matter what
we do to the data and here's why for
those of you who don't like to look at
different diff regression tables it's
because for most countries if you simply
graph the data
natural resource production and in red
there polity score which is a standard
metric in the literature to measure
democracy what you'll find is as natural
resource production goes up democracy
increases this is trinidad tobago
actually one of the the data for
trinidad and tobago red is polity Green
is the percentage of government revenues
that come from oil gas and minerals Blue
is total fuel income per capita in real
terms what you'll find is as natural
resource production goes up democracy
increases de Mexico similar story
Venezuela shockingly a similar story
Venezuela democra we have Google Chavez
today but as well actually democratize
during an oil boom they're also
authoritarian countries such as Angola
which while they never became democratic
saw at least a one standard deviation
increase in their polity score during an
oil boom Algeria is another example now
this isn't to say you can't find cases
that look like they might be cursed
Zambia is one point we want to make is
one case does not justify theory okay
the canonical cases Libya Saudi Arabia
etc they were autocracies before they
found oil they stayed autocracies after
one of the points we want to make about
many of these countries there were
autocracies in antiquity okay the bottom
line of the hundred and sixty eight
countries in our data set 53 were oil or
mineral reliant of those 5319 appear to
have been blessed by oil and minerals
eight appear to be potentially cursed 7
display no discernible pattern at all
and 19 worked autocracies before they
found oil and remain so afterwards we
would have liked to argue that those 19
would have democratized had they not
found oil but in order to do that we'd
have to throw out history think about it
what would a rock without oil look like
when closest
approximation is Jordan or Syria what
would a kha'zix down without oil look
like the closest approximation
Uzbekistan what would a Saudi Arabia
without oil look like the best
approximation Yemen not England in fact
and this is what inspired this next part
of the discussion this theory about
rainfall of the 19 that are autocracies
before they find oil gas and minerals 15
are clustered in two areas of the world
where virtually all of the countries
those with oil and those without have
been autocracies for centuries I'm
thinking of the Middle East North Africa
and Central Asia think about it Yemen
has very little oil it is a chakra see
Saudi Arabia its nearest neighbor has
oil in as an autocracy so as a
scientific matter it's very difficult to
claim that oil caused Saudi Arabia to be
autocratic but it suggests that there's
some regional there's something
associated with geography that's not oil
we want it we wanted to know what that
was now we might have saved ourselves a
lot of work had we taken history even
more seriously instead of spending three
years gathering data I like to joke that
we should have spent three weeks reading
well stuff subs work because if you
would do that you would you would
realize that first all the persistent
autocracies today or not all that many
of them have had autocratic governance
system since antiquity this isn't just
the Persian Empire the core of the
Persian Empire the the core of what was
at the time the Mesopotamian system
under the Acadians and the and the like
it's the countries that were also
conquered by them the other point I want
to make is that the
is very there's variants and regime type
in antiquity particularly the Greek
city-states in the Roman Republic and
finally had we looked at a place in the
untick whaty that should have been
cursed by minerals it should have been
Athens which had silver mines which
became the basis for Athenian coinage
which gave Athens a tremendous advantage
over other city-states so some place
according to this theory in the ancient
world should have been her autocracy it
should have been Athens so it suggests
there's something else at work and it
suggests that their countries are their
political regimes are equilibria certain
countries keep returning to an
equilibrium autocracies others to
experimenting with democracy it suggests
the data suggests that that equilibria
is being driven by a geographic factor
and the data suggests that that
Geographic factor can't be oil gas or
minerals because first places that don't
have it are also autocratic like Egypt
has very look very little oil gas and
minerals but as autocratic it's there's
something regional going on and it's
second that events in the 20th century
could not cause things that happened in
antiquity now one hint for what it is
that's driving it what is this
Geographic factor can be found in rostov
saves 1932 Caravan cities where roast of
stuff went out to many of the cities
such as Petra in order to do
archaeological investigations and as you
read Caravan cities what's really
striking about them or what's striking
about your stuffs depiction of them is
how dry they are there's small bands of
rainfall that a small bands of
agriculture around the cities but then
he comments on how little agriculture
there is at a short distance from these
cities and so we wondered does low
rainfall coincide with persistent
autocracy so the first thing we did
major innovation in political science
methodology
he was to look at a map of the world
okay I thought that was funny these are
countries blue is countries that receive
less than 50 centimeters of rainfall per
year this is in 2008 although there's
not a lot of time series change
countries don't jump around from being
deserts to being savannas overnight and
I'll talk a bit about that later on so
these are countries that receive less
than 50 centimeters of rainfall a year
which is generally taken by agronomist
instead of the minimum to sustain serial
agriculture these are the autocracies
you notice that there's not a perfect
fit we wouldn't want we wouldn't expect
our to be one but there is an overlap so
then we wondered well if you switch it
if you go in reverse what happens so
here's countries that receive moderate
rainfall between 50 and 100 centimeters
a year and the world's democracies you
notice again well there's a high degree
of overlap it's not perfect but the
pattern is not random either so we
wondered what would happen if we just
graph the data so the stable democracies
of the world places that have been
democracies for 20 years or more
persistently are in blue the places that
are have always been autocracies at
least back to their independence are in
red and you'll notice that at very low
levels of rainfall there's only three
democracies Israel Botswana and Cyprus
at under 50 centimetres everything else
is autocratic from roughly 50
centimetres to a hundred centimeters the
democracies outnumber the autocracies
I'll show you the summary statistics in
a minute and then above 100 centimeters
there seems to be sort of equal numbers
of each ello more autocracies on balance
than democracies look there's something
here so what's the distribution okay
fifty percent of the world stable
democracies fall into the moderate
rainfall band between 50 and 100
centimeters
only ten percent of the world's
autocracies fall into stable autocracies
fall into that rainfall band countries
that flop back and forth places like
Nigeria Democratic one afternoon
autocratic the next they're about in
there in this rain fall band about
twenty five percent of the world
countries that cycle like this are this
are in the stable are excuse me are in
the moderate rainfall band now what
happens if you look at low rainfall
under 50 centimetres eight percent of
the world's democracies are found at
under 50 centimeters of rainfall year
almost half of the world's persistent
autocracies are found that under 50
centimeters of rainfall a year and about
fifteen percent of the world's regime
cyclers are found just to something
going on with rainfall there's some
pattern to be explained here why do we
think moderate rainfall matters for
democracy and low levels of rainfall
drive autocracy and at higher levels of
rainfall there's a mix this is from the
Department of Agriculture it's the
inherent land quality assessment it's
basically an assessment of what can be
grown and you'll notice the areas in
white these are the places that score a
low on both of their characteristics
these are the places where they're
basically saying agriculture is very
difficult what happens to coincide with
the places that are very dry and
persistently autocratic the areas in red
these are rain forests also areas where
you don't find a lot of democracies
there are some but it also suggests it
scores very low on what's called the
soil performance metric suggesting that
soils are thin so we think it has
something to do that rainfall has an
effect on democracy through agriculture
what's the mechanism
so we hypothesized that moderate
rainfall at the right time of the year
over a broad area on a predictable basis
allows a society to create a storable
surplus that surplus surplus can be
stored locally because nobody owns the
rain essentially these are the Greek
city-states local communities with the
ability to that is local people banding
together to store surplus for the future
to get them through or perhaps difficult
harvest the next year or the year after
that that means when you aggregate these
local communities up into something that
looks like a nation state you've built
horizontal accountability into the way
the states put together this in fact is
the history of your of Western Europe
where as feudalism as the feudal system
became modern territorial states what
had to happen was the King how to
negotiate with local Nobles what did he
have to give them here to put them in a
house of lords they served as the first
courts they served as the first tax
collectors we think of them today is
inconsequential because today they are
inconsequential but in the early stages
of the development of representative
institutions they were very important
and they're important because they were
local centers of power but second
there's something else about moderate
levels of rainfall and it has to do with
what you can grow at moderate levels of
rainfall now since I'm from New York
City I know all about agriculture well I
didn't but my advisor did the late kind
of sailcloth and one asanka lofts great
discoveries was that cereals and legumes
that is things like wheat corn lima
beans lentils have very modest scale
economies in production these things can
be grown on small farms that is to say
on family farms this isn't like sugar
which is always growing on very large
plantations often with forced labor
it means that societies that are based
on cereals and legumes are more likely
they are not destined to but they are
more likely to have an egalitarian
social structure when you put the two
together horizontal accountability that
is representative institutions for
elites and an egalitarian social
structure you are more likely to produce
democratic institutions that in time can
become a democratic political system and
I want it's just time we're talking on
the scale of centuries not afternoons
but centuries okay if rainfall is good
why is it more rainfall better here
again I rely on my knowledge as a native
New Yorker that at high levels of
rainfall is very okay I thought that's
funny at high levels of rainfall it's
really hard to grow cereals rain at the
wrong time of year especially of a lot
of it knocks down cereal crops this is
one of the reasons incidentally why the
Irish went to the potato so quickly that
the oak crop would get ruined by
inopportune rains too much rain also
causes cereal crop roots to rot now this
isn't to say you can't grow anything in
the tropics you can grow bananas cassava
and yams very well in the tropics what
are yams cassava and bananas all have in
common versus cereals you can't store
them as anybody who's ever made banana
bread knows a banana keeps for six days
a cassava keeps for six days and a yam
even under the best of conditions will
keep for 18 weeks that is to say you
can't get from one failed harvest to the
next by relying on storage on stored
food the only way you can store the food
is in your own body it should be little
wonder then that the states that grew up
around these kinds of tree crops and
tubers tended to be poor tended to not
be long-lived and tenants could not
sustain a population for long periods of
time
when the for example the Europeans went
to Africa the one proto state they found
was the kingdom of the Congo what was
interesting about the kingdom of the
Congo was how poor it was when the
Europeans arrived it had a predatory
ruling class but that predatory ruling
class was amazingly poor it didn't
become rich until they realized you
could export human beings they had
cities of miniscule size less than 3,000
typically and they had a very very weak
state structure why are there few
democracies and deserts well for obvious
reasons even New Yorkers know that you
can't grow corn in a desert there's not
enough rainfall most of the population
are going to be long distance traders or
pastoral nomads in fact these are the
people that antiquity connected the
Roman Empire and China that is the
people that ran the caravans across the
Arabian desert in Central Asia that
society will be tribal and mobile no we
don't know of any tribal and mobile
society that gave rise until the 20th
century to a modern state nevermind a
democratic one think about this for a
minute neither the Egyptian Akkadian
Persian Athenian Macedonian Roman
Ottoman French and British Empire's
actually colonized the Arabian Peninsula
they all got to its borders and stopped
Alexander actually wanted to conquer
arabia he died before there was the
opportunity but certainly his generals
decided that wasn't a very good idea why
did they stop because there was nothing
there at the time worth exploiting when
the Arabian Peninsula creates
nation-states it's in the 20th century
and when those nations states when it
becomes worth while to put a fence
around them and call them a country
because they have oil so I relief act
like to to remind my students that a
Saudi Arabia without oil might look like
Somalia
okay now how can we know that low
rainfall correlates with social and
political structures that are not likely
to produce democracy I need to ask your
forbearance for a minute and talk a bit
about instrumental variable regressions
I promise there'll be no quiz about this
there's no consensus metric in the
literature for for the social and
economic structures not likely to
produce democracy but here's what we do
know we know that mobile tribal
societies did not give rise to democracy
in the past sort of obvious reasons they
don't give rise the states we can
therefore use the degree to which a
society is mobile and tribal as a proxy
for the lack of institutions associated
with democratic governance and so we
created an index of tribal nomadism
which is nothing more than the number of
times that the experts who wrote the
entries in the Encyclopedia Britannica
use the words Bedouin tribe tribal clan
and nomads in the description of
countries so we have some hypotheses
first and we can test them and I want to
be clear here we may turn out to be
wrong and we're happy to be wrong first
low rainfall should be associated with
social and political structures that are
not likely to produce democracy that is
to say a high score on the tribalism
nomads index second low rainfall should
be associated statistically with
autocracy third low rainfall should be
working on autocracy through those
social and political structures fourth
moderate rainfall should be associated
with political structures likely to
produce democracy that is with a low
score on the gnomon ISM tribalism index
fifth moderate rainfall is associated
with democracy six moderate rainfall
works on democracy
to social and political structures which
is to say through low scores on that
index and seven that at high levels of
rainfall these patterns attenuate all
right so this is on the y-axis the score
on the nomadism tribalism index along
the x-axis is the amount of rainfall
blue diamonds are stable democracies red
dots are persistent autocracies and the
little green squares are regime cyclers
what pattern jumps out of the graph well
at low levels of rainfall lots of tribal
nomadism which dissipates very quickly
once you hit about 50 centimeters a year
and rainfall that is once you hit hit an
environment that will permit you to
sustain agriculture nomadic tribalism
disappears stands to reason what's a
caravan trader going to do in Iowa
second you can see the stable
democracies are clustering here between
50 and 100 centimeters of rainfall and
the stable democracies are scoring very
low on the tribalism index with one
exception India but one exception to the
rule does not overturn a theory this is
a probabilistic theory if we simply
graph the marginal effective rainfall on
stable democracy you find that it's
democracy excuse me as rainfall goes up
up to a particular breakpoint I'll talk
about in a minute the probability of
democracy goes up okay so now we're
going to run some regressions I hope
these are visible or legible in the back
they're barely legible here here's what
they show we want to know is there a
relationship between rainfall levels and
game types controlling for competing
theories its oil it's high GDP its your
economic growth rate it's the region of
the world you located and so what we did
was estimate some ordered logit
regressions with the three regime types
on the left side that is regime cycler
stable democracy stable autocracy the
emitted variable for those who care is
the persistent autocracies and we and we
have we measure rainfall as three cubic
splines each of which tells us what the
relationship that is each of which
captures a particular kind of ecology of
rainfall very low moderate very high
what are the results show well it shows
that there that if you are a in the
moderate rainfall ban the probability
that is the first cubic-spline that
there is that as you move in the in the
first rainfall band up to the to the the
breakpoint you find that as rainfall
increases democracy increases the log
odds and being a stable democracy jump
if you're in the second spline which is
point where it begins to flatten out you
find that the log odds of being a stable
democracy continue to increase but much
more much more slowly and at the very
high levels of rainfall again you get a
log odds of being a democracy
controlling for other characteristics
continue to go up okay now we need to
show that for the theory to work that
the that democracy and rainfall are
connecting through institutions so here
we use something called an instrumental
variables regression in which we first
strip out the part of the tribalism
nomads index which is endogenous to
the regime types and we do that by
running a regression of tribalism on
rainfall we plug the residuals in as the
two the second stage of the regression
and what do we find we find that as
tribalism goes up controlling for the
fact that we've stripped out its
endogenous component with rainfall
democracy goes down can graph this as
the marginal effect of tribalism nomadic
tribalism on democracy and you can see
doesn't show up particularly well here
but the time you get to eight there is
the probability of demeaning a democracy
is about zero all right to wrap up the
laws of probability should work at all
points not just in the recent period so
we asked what were the first experiments
with representative institutions that we
know of all the Greek city-states new
roman republic now we're not suggesting
that the greek city-states in the roman
republic had democracy in the way we
think of it today I'm also aware that
there was variance in ancient Greece but
I'm also aware as runciman pointed out
that even the great oligarchies of the
Greek city-states were highly democratic
when compared to places like Veronica
gypped we think about Sparta they had
the Guru SIA they had the f-4s all of
which limited the power of the king by
the end making the king somewhat of a
figurehead what rainfall band the de
Roman Republic and the Greek city-states
fall in the moderate rainfall band what
do we know about their social and
economic structures but we know from the
work of Ian Morris the Greek city-states
even the Oleg our keys were remarkably a
gala tarian what do we know about their
agricultural systems we need that we
know they produce lots of store will
crops now we know we have work to do on
this in order to make this case more
airtight than it is so what are we doing
well since the opportunity
my time is very low the first thing
we've done is we've gotten the data from
the from the National Oceanographic and
Atmospheric Administration on the on
rainfall and temperature for every
weather station by months and 1697 to
see whether or not as we run these
regressions in past panels if we still
get the same result I mean second we're
we're looking at increasingly
restrictive democracy windows that is
looking at windows in the past third
we're adding additional control
variables to the regressions things like
temperature presence of irrigation to
see if there's a whit fog effect
linguistic fragmentation which is a
popular coefficient in or a popular
variable added to these regressions and
forth and I think perhaps most
importantly we're reading more ancient
history thank you very much let me now
give the floor to Naomi lamoreaux
well it's with a lot of trepidation
actually that I agreed to do this today
because i'm a modern historian a modern
US economic historian with no training
in a classical history or ancient
history and so I was like what am I
doing here but Joe has a vision and I
would and I would very much like to be a
part of his vision and his vision is a
fostering more discussion between
historians of the ancient world and
historians that work on on modern
periods and he put this this two-day
event together with with that in mind
Steve haber has as always interesting in
has just laid out what is a a really
intriguing potential path for a kind of
cross era discussion about history and
about the determinants of democracy and
autocracy and I'm sure that you will
have lots to say about his use of
evidence from the ancient from ancient
times to to make his case so I'm see my
function is using my comparative
advantage as a modern historian what I
would like to do and in my comment is
look at his argument from the
perspective of a modern historian who
can think about the modern parts of his
argument and give you a sense than of
where the ground is solid where the
basis for comparative comparison with
the ancient world is solid and where the
ground may be a little more treacherous
and we might be wary of the comparisons
so let me start by saying a bit about
the resource curse
the basic idea or the the basic picture
that captures the idea of a research
resource curse is this kind of a diagram
which this particular one appeared in a
paper by Jeff Sachs and an Andruw Warner
and what this picture shows is on the is
on the horizontal axis my labels
disappeared Steve I put let Steve put
this in his PowerPoint my labels
disappear been the bottom axis is the
extent to which resources the horizontal
axis the extent to which resources are
important in a particular economy and
the vertical axis is the extent is the
rate of growth of GDP per capita and
when you look at this picture then you
see there seems to be a negative
association between the growth rate of
the economy this data came from the 20th
century the late 20th century but a
growth a negative association between
the growth rate of the economy and the
extent to which resources were important
in the economy and this this picture
puzzled sex and Warner and puzzled lots
of people because they thought that
resources should be good for for a
growth if you if your country was able
to export resources than that should
raise your income that should raise your
ability to bite imports you should be
able to invest more your economy should
be able to grow more but it didn't seem
to be borne out by this picture and so
historian are so economist and political
scientists came up with a number of
hypotheses Steve talked about some of
them about what might explain this kind
of picture and and actually there's a
virtual cottage industry in these
disciplines of testing the resource
curse and finding its validity now
there's a basic problem with the
resource curse idea which I think Steve
talked about but I'm going to put it in
a very simple way which is that suppose
that country's growth rate as a function
of some other factor let's just say the
quality of its institutions and suppose
further that for some completely
unrelated reason more countries more of
the countries that have poor
institutions institutions of poor
quality also turn out to be countries
with a lot of natural resource exports
well if that's the case then the
correlation the relationship that we
observe between a country's growth rate
and its resource experts is exports this
is spurious it's that other thing that
matters now you can see that something
like this may in fact be going on from a
recent study done by how firm a loan and
a number of other scholars and what they
did was something really very similar
simple they took the data that was in
that other picture I showed you and
divided it into two pictures and they
just use paldi scores are similar to the
ones that Steve used in his analysis and
they divided the sample in exactly half
and those with the better policy scores
like they called countries with good
institutions and those with worst
quality scores they called countries
with bad institutions but they just
divided the sample and a half so there's
a lot of countries with that we might
think don't have such good institutions
and in this good institution side but
regardless when you look at this if you
look at the picture of good institutions
that negative correlation between
exports and growth disappears it's flat
but if you look at the bad institutions
picture you see it it's really only in
the bad institutions country countries
that you get that that negative
relationship now if so so this looks
pretty dead right this idea of a
resource curse looks pretty dead and you
know the coffin is closing on it and
they can reach their hands on say but
wait wait a minute we can still be
viable if something if there's something
about natural resource abundance that
causes bad institutions
and I think here's where Steven his
co-author Victor have have really made a
big contribution they have really nailed
this this this coffin shut what they've
done and this is really solid ground for
you to compare work do your comparisons
on they've collected data and resource
dependence and institutions for a set of
countries sometimes for as long a period
is over two centuries and they find two
things and this is I'm just summarizing
very briefly what steve told you today
which is they found that institutional
quality was basically generally set
before resource exploitation became
economically important and then they
actually show when you look at these
long time series what you see is that
the development of resource exports
sometimes improved institutional quality
or often in quite a few cases improved
institutional quality rather than
lowering it okay so this is great this
is really solid ground more recently
they've gone beyond this to to ponder
that question that is lingering in the
background and that's this question what
then explains why so many of the
countries with valuable natural
resources had low quality institutions
to to begin with and and here's where I
think the ground gets a little less
solid okay the answer that they offer
connects institutions with geography in
a different way with rainfall and I'm
not going to rehearse this argument for
you you've you've just heard it you've
just heard it and really eloquently
expressed in great great detail it's
creative it's intriguing and it's
certainly plausible but being creative
and intriguing implausible is is not
enough right so I tell my students sort
of more than anything else is that all
the hypotheses that we take seriously
are by definition plausible or else we
wouldn't take them seriously right so
what we have to do is we have to go
further we have to see if they withstand
scrutiny against the evidence if they
stand up not just a not only not only
whether they're consistent with the
evidence would but whether they stand up
against alternative hypotheses that one
might pose so let's look a little bit of
Steve's evidence okay so you saw this
picture in slightly different colors I
don't know I took it off his half his
paper so it's our different computers
and and you can see that it's certainly
consistent with the story that he tells
in that you really find almost no
democracies at very low levels of
rainfall you've got a lot of democracy
stable democracies concentrated in the
in the parts of the world with moderate
rainfall and then after that it gets a
little more mixed but they're at high
levels of rainfall up there are more
less democracy than autocracies now I
think it's the especially the lower part
of this is really convincing but a lot
of the action in the world a lot of what
we really care about when we want when
we're thinking about the world is not in
those lower in those countries in the
desert but really the rest of this
picture and what I want to suggest that
that there are other stories that might
at least plausibly generate pictures
like this so one story we might tell us
that democracy is contagious in some way
so it might be that if you're if if the
country next to you becomes Democratic
that you're somehow more likely to
become Democratic now there are lots of
stories that you can tell that my
producers effect one might be that you
trade a lot more with countries that are
close to you and as you trade more and
exchange goods you exchange ideas you
exchange lots of things and that might
affect your propensity to switch into
the Democratic camp if you're trading
with the democratic country
another possible by the way if you read
the New York Times Book Review this
weekend there was a review of book by a
new book by Timothy Garton ash that
makes this kind of argument it may be
that if you're next to a democratic
country you might like more likely to be
conquered by it and there's an argument
in the literature for example that
Napoleon conquered a lot of countries in
Europe and change their institutions in
the way that made them more likely
become to grow and become more
democratic later on alright so there's
there's a bunch of stories that you
could tell and if for some kind of
idiosyncratic reason a country became
democratic and that affected its
neighboring countries and if the country
that came became democratic was in an
area of moderate rainfall then the
contagion effect would also likely
affect countries of moderate rainfall
because countries of moderate rainfall
tend to be next to each other and so you
might then get a spurious relationship
okay now um such I should say that Steve
actually controls through this in his
regression analysis but I'm goodness
suggests that this is probably not
enough and so let me get me first show
you this this pic this is his picture of
stable democracies and the first thing
you notice they really do clump right
like they're all there with a few
exceptions they're all sort of clustered
together okay and they're mostly
clustered in the regions of moderate
rainfall and you can see this if you put
his two to meps next to each other the
one exception is Latin America where the
clump involves countries with higher
rain falls but but otherwise they're
mainly these democracies are mainly
clumped in in areas of moderate rainfall
and so we have this problem is is this a
coincidence or is this a causal
relationship between moderate rainfall
and and and and these these clumped
democracies and Steve tries to get at
here this with his with his estimations
both by controlling for neighboring
democracies and by using instrumental
variable techniques to get at causation
um but I'm not sure that this solves the
problem and the reason I'm not sure that
this solves the problem is because all
of these cross-country regressions take
their cases this quantitative method has
as its basic unit of analysis of country
the cases are countries and the results
depend on the number of countries that
fall into each of the categories but the
number of countries in each of these
regions of the world and also the
boundaries among these countries are the
end products of historical processes and
we might want to think about those
historical processes think about whether
there's alternative explanations that we
might want to worry about here okay so
now that I'm going to end by asking you
to engage in a little thought experiment
what we call it what we'll call it a
counterfactual exercise in quantitative
history okay now my counterfactual is
let's suppose Rome had never declined
that the Roman Empire had never fallen
apart okay but let's suppose that China
Chinese Empire over here which is an
autocratic you know had declined in the
Chinese Empire had fallen apart into a
lot of little countries now if we assume
that nothing else was different nothing
nothing else mattered then what would
happen is our number of cases of
democracies would fall dramatically
because all those European countries
would just be one now but I number of
autocratic cases in the moderate
rainfall region because China's in his
moderate rainfall region would have
increased dramatically right we would
have a lot of and if you run the same
regression she would have gotten
different results ok so my parting
thought to you is it that that is that
plot experiment assumes that all all
things being equal Europe would still
have been democratic and China would
still have been autocratic but of course
it's likely right it's that all things
would not have been equal so one can
think what would China have been like
what would those policies have been like
if if if the Empire had collapsed and
there have been a lot of separate
countries we could also think what would
Europe have been like if Rome had never
collapsed if all of Europe was one
Empire and and it's quite possible it's
quite likely than that that that Empire
might not have been democratic that
Europe might not be green in in that
counter factual scenario so if this if
this counterfactual exercise stimulates
your thinking then it should bring you
back to the questions that classical
scholars are sort of really familiar
with right so why what is the story of
the rise and fall of Empires what it why
did Rome decline and it may be through
that platt process then that we all get
a different set of hypotheses about why
parts of the world are democratic and
and why they are not and so with that
I'll stop and just a custody to come
back here very spirited discussion
before opening things up to questions
let me address the last issue raised by
Naomi with a story about lost asif so as
Joe Manning pointed out lost our self
was a Russian émigré and he had quite a
thick Russian accent and so in his
classes at Yale he wanted to explain why
the Roman Empire fell and students all
semester long kept hearing him say that
it was about the combing of the goats
that the Roman Empire fell because of
the combing of the goats and finally at
the end of the semester one of the
students went to his office hours and
said you know professor Ross Stavros
Joseph I'm really having a hard time
understanding how the combing goat could
have caused the fall of the Roman Empire
Andros tosev looked at him quizzically
and said the coming of the Goths so one
of the nice things about Naomi's
critique is that we can in fact subject
it to a test so if we took Italy Spain
France Greece out of the Roman Empire
assume that which is we could make them
one country assume that they'd be
democratic we can just rerun the
regressions assume they'd be autocratic
and rerun the aggressions and see what
would happen let's assume the roman
empire and everyone away we can also
take China and divide it up into its can
see what it would have been its
constituent kingdoms and run those
regressions and see do we still get the
same result that is our result robust so
that's obviously something that we need
to do in order to make this case
genuinely compelling before I take
questions I want to be clear about what
the goal all this is that it is uncommon
upon me as a researcher to make the case
that means that I have to try very hard
to overturn the argument
it may turn out and the debate that
ensues that I'm wrong but that's okay
because science still advances when you
do that